this U.S women's player and daughter of
former NBA legend is about to be the
next big thing in soccer meet Trinity
Rodman Rodman was supposed to go to
Washington State but jump straight to
the pros without playing a single
Collegiate game due to covid at just 18
she was drafted second overall by the
Washington Spirit setting a record for
the youngest player drafted there since
then her name has been all over the
record books Rodman scored in her first
nwsl game and became the youngest goal
scorer at that time she won Rookie of
the Year and helped them capture their
first championship Rodman also scored
twice against Wales and became the
youngest player in women's history to
score a brace at the national level
although the stakes may continue to get
more difficult Trinity Rodman has
already shown that she is ready to
become the next biggest sensation in
women's soccer